foreign
's YouTube channel today we will learn
how to create a table in SQL but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn now without
further Ado let's try to get started
with our agenda how to create table in
SQL
now let's quickly look at the syntax we
need to create a table in SQL so we will
be using the keyword create to let the
SQL know that we're trying to create an
element which can be a table or database
followed by that we will be using the
table keyword to explain the SQL that we
are trying to create a table here
followed by that a customized table name
then inside that we will be starting
with the parameters which can be the
elements or columns which are present in
your table column 1 or parameter 1 its
data type and constraint so what is a
constraint we will be understanding
about the data wrapping constraint when
we are in the Practical mode Let's
quickly try to understand the syntax
over here so these are the things create
keyword table keyword table name which
is a customized or user defined name for
the table then the parameters involved
in the table that is the columns column
one two three data type and constraint
followed by that close the bracket and
use the semicolon to explain SQL that it
is the end of the code now let's get
back to the SQL workbench so we'll log
into the SQL workbench so now we have
logged into the SQL workbench now
previously we had created a database
that is simply learn database now we
will try to create the table in the same
database now we will be using the create
keyword
table
now table name which can be anything
let's try to create a student database
or employee database
you can see that
I'm using capitals for keywords and
Smalls for the user defined ones just to
make it clear for the reader to
understand what I saw what if it is in
capital it is a keyword if it isn't
small it is a user defined name now EMP
ID
which is an integer type and then
the constraint
not null
so remember the data type and
constraints that we discussed earlier so
this is it so you're trying to tell the
SQL that the ID what you're creating is
of integer data type and since this can
be a primary keyword it should not be
null right now the next one
employee name
which can be character data type so
let's keep it as c h a r character
and let's give the size as 115.
now the next one
okay I forgot to give the constraint
default
okay let's not keep this default now it
cannot be null as well
then comes the address
which can again be character
and let's give it as 500 as the
size
and followed by that
it can be default
here we are trying to tell SQL that it
is okay to keep the employee address
column as null it can be blank again
it's your wish if you don't want the
address column to be empty you can keep
it as not null and if it's all right for
you to keep it as null then you can
provide it as default null right so
these are the parameters their data
types and the constraints
right now we will understand them a
little more detail in the theoretical
section now followed by The Columns the
last one is to dedicate or create a
primary key let SQL know which is a
primary key so primary key is very
important for every database or table
and I'll explain you that in the
theoretical section again now which is
the primary key the ID what we created
for employees that is EMP ID is the
primary key this particular primary key
will be really important when we are
trying to work with two different tables
with one single column in common between
both the tables right so with that we
have created the code for creating a new
table in a database now let's quickly
try to execute it so there is a small
error let's try to resolve it
yes so the small error that we created
is we did not try to select a database
right before creating a table you need
to select the database or explain SQL
which database is supposed to be used
now for that we have to use the use
keyword and the database name that has
simply learn DB
semicolon now when you run this
particular code SQL will understand we
need to use the simply learn DB and then
it will get access to that particular DB
then it will read this particular code
and try to create a new table let's
quickly run it
and there you go
let's try to eliminate this code for a
while run this now we are using the
simply learndb
eliminate this code
now
on this particular code once again and
okay
so instead of character we can use
worker
and run it
since character limit was 255 and we
gave 500 instead of character if we
provide worker we can provide the
maximum limit so now the table is
successfully created here so that's how
you can create a new table in SQL with
that we have component of this tutorial
on how to create a new table in SQL and
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
Express will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at your list
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here